this encampment this area according to
city officials about half of the
unsheltered as the homeless are referred
to in this city live along the highway
or in the underpass or parks the
navigation team comes and gives them a
warning of several days that there will
be a cleanup giving them an opportunity
to move to a shelter store their
belongings and the rest is just thrown
away we actually literally have people
call and say can you send the now team
to us they're crying for help yeah and
so we're going to send somebody their
way and definitely have one of our
system navigators connect with them and
lose them towards getting into shelter
on the morning of we may not know how
many people are here right there's about
a dozen or so individuals here earlier
this week this morning to take a lot
less I'll take some time to actually go
through the property and look for items
that meet our criteria for storage we'll
bag those and essentially bag you and
then we'll take them to storage